hello everybody my name is Mark Clark
welcome back to will you press the
button now again should I need to
explain this I don't think so so first
question is if your waifu could exist in
real life and would love you they can
appear anywhere in the world would you
press the button right you know to be
honestly i don't know who my waifu would
be there's a lot of videogame characters
that could be my waifu but one of the
obvious things is if your waifu was an
obvious character from say an anime or a
video game or something like that and
they existed in the real world anywhere
and you have to find them they would be
obvious they would look like their video
game character and what if they come
from a different medieval time or with
magic and stuff and they actually had
those things it would be really obvious
where they were depending on who you
pixel I would press the button but I
don't exactly know who I would do oh
it's not exactly a downside though but I
mean you will meet your ideal partner be
it a mate a life partner a best bud etc
will stick by your side till the day you
die but you no longer have the ability
to enjoy music and every song from
what's on the radio to the jingles and
commercial will sound like whip my hair
okay I actually don't listen to music
that much on my own not that I don't
like song I do like listening in music I
just when I'm driving in my car I'm
listening to silence I'm thinking
because that's my thinking time so I
honestly wouldn't mind that because I
don't even have the ability to enjoy
music like it's like there it would be
amazing if I could meet my ideal partner
um a best butterfl life partner whatever
it doesn't matter
that would be cool oh my god I guess I'm
weird in that like I don't technically
listen to music all that much I'm a
little hot I like music I wanna make
music I don't listen dude you rather
become a great become a great at singing
and using instruments of your own
choosing but develop a cocaine addiction
if you were ever to use you use your
skill professionally addiction is
incurable well that seems like what a
lot of rock stars do already when they
become great at singing in the
instruments of my own choosing but I
develop a cocaine addiction that doesn't
sound good but I mean if you're great at
it like really really great but you can
learn the skills to be great without
taking the route of the cocaine but this
is you know your waifu becomes real this
seems familiar but whenever you see her
you transform into a 3-story
oh that's amazing I so want Matt oh I
want that that sounds incredible Oh
make it sing oh that's amazing
oh that's amazing I love that this okay
you get all the computer hardware and
software you want for free the rest of
your life but you must always have the
latest and most likely unpopular
Microsoft operating system itself okay
there's meat I upgrade whenever there's
an upgrade I've been through the bad
ones I've been through the good ones
frankly I do just fine if I can get all
that stuff free and I have to use that
I'm okay with this it's it's okay it's
what I do it in real life anyway
free stuff super computer you can have a
super computer running on Windows you
find a dollar but you stub your toe oh
you evil evil demon oh you evil demon I
will not I will not there is no way stub
your toe for a dollar that's what that
is
stop here hit yours hurt yourself for a
dollar don't hurt yourself
that's the end of that skit you
guarantee the survival of the human race
for the next 10,000 years but nobody
will travel beyond the moon for 10
Wow I'd rather take the risk of toughing
it out on our own than hinder ourselves
and not be able to go outside the moon
because as soon as we go outside the
moon then we all blow up anyway it's
like you prolong the possibility of
extinction or do you go take the juice
I'd rather go right now I will not press
there's no way I mean we may die in 100
years thousand years who knows but we
may also live in that extraordinary
advances in technology the bird amazing
incredible we eat her out maybe that's
what happens to commanded maybe that's
what happens until then strive for
innovation reach for the stars you can
fly but you have to be Noah while you're
doing it I would do that if my my powers
are powered by the fact that I'm
screaming my Odin day I know they're
reverting to Noah like probably from the
Bible but still like it doesn't say you
live a very happy life with whomever you
desire but you make a new random enemy
every day okay so let's do a math
problem you make a new random enemy
which some people do every day anyway so
let's say you live a very happy life you
know you got you got your happy life
which is probably like 60 70 years let's
call it 70 just to be generous about you
got 70 years of good life with whoever
you want and I'm assuming you can change
that decision if you want to be what is
your happy life you'd be happy the 365
days sense it that's 25,000 new end
so you got 25,550 people that hate you
and enemies but that is cumulative so it
goes up through time you know it's not
not immediate anyway but it goes up a
little bit each time now each one of
these people that hates you how much do
they want to take away your happiness
and how much of them are so convicted in
the ability to hate you there's so much
your enemy that they recruit others into
talking about how bad you are and then
those people recruit their guys and that
they contact you fish viciously honey
Dart
wait no this is a moot point it says
right here you live a very happy life so
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter you
live a happy life okay you drive any car
you want but you can't bring a girl into
it okay they ride on the roof then I
guess that's fine cars aren't my thing I
don't care I don't care I don't care
about cars it doesn't matter to me I'll
get a Ferrari for your 21st birthday
party but you can't drive it okay
someone's trying to be Trixie here with
the button they wrote it and they said
I'll get a Ferrari on ma they'll get a
Ferrari on my 21st birthday and then I
can't drive it this is a trick question
you can't run one past me I'm too smart
for you I ain't gonna press that button
because you want the Ferrari and not me
I know what he's up to
I know what he's up to you will become
the richest most famous most hottest
person in the world everyone will love
you and you will get everything you wish
for but all of that will go away after
ten years you will end up living in a
box on a street corner begging for money
from mostly the rest of you tonight why
is it same mostly what's the condition
for mostly there are people gonna
remember you from when you were the
richest most famous hot person in the
world ten years is a good time
which is most famous I mean everything
you wish for could be world peace and
all that stuff and you could buy
everything you know you could buy food
for the poor you could do so much good
in the world in those 10 years and then
you end up living in a box on the street
Corder what if you abolish homelessness
while you're the most risk famous person
then you know like when you're living in
a box you just keep putting the shelter
and you to live it over life I would
press that button
really 71% of people would not press the
button 71 people are not thinking
properly
what you could do in ten years what you
could do what you could influence in 10
years is amazing don't discredit power
of me when I'm desperate don't do it
ever I don't know why I just want to say
that you can go back to your favorite
year in your lifetime with the same age
you had been but you have to live in
this year and having that age forever oh
so it's like a groundhog day of the same
year over and over again so let's say I
wanted to go back to say when I was 21
not to tell it's a good time in my life
but let's go back in one I was 21 I have
to live that year over and over again
with no progression I would get so out
of my mind bored and insane there's no
errors Oh
you become incredibly attractive to
everyone else but you are hideously
disgusting to yourself that is really
interesting that is really interesting
so you're attractive on the outside but
you hate yourself inside that is that is
real that's like a psychology question
right there that is really interesting
oh man and that's why I'm gonna cop out
and not answer it myself and leave that
one up to you guys so answer please in
the comments below debate which side is
better you could be incredibly
attractive but would it be worth it to
hate yourself and look in the mirror and
see only ugliness could you live with
that would you get used to that like the
do the benefits of being attractive to
everyone else outweigh the hatred that
you have for yourself in your heart like
wouldn't you rather live a life where
you learn average-looking and maybe
above-average looking but and but you
were happy with who you are in cyclic
wouldn't that be a better decision than
being incredibly attractive but living
with that burden I don't know that's why
I leave it up to you guys so thank you
everybody so much for watching I look
forward to reading your responses I know
this is gonna be an interesting one so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video come on broke into
the storage ship
what the hell for coins not kinda for
gun more enemy Philip